if they would let me be some Syrian I
guess they will there is no one for
whose talent I have more respect than
the gentleman who is about to present
the winner of the Best Actress in a
supporting role mr. Anthony Quinn
[Applause]
how are you hi jack hi Tony I see you're
back hey wait what do you mean back
weren't you here a couple of years ago
to pick up an Oscar oh yes yeah you got
one too didn't you - yeah - I see well
that I hear you're a director now
no that's right by the way huh you're
still acting aren't you
[Music]
the best supporting actress nominees are
Carolyn Jones the bachelor party Elsa
Lanchester witness for the prosecution
hope Lange Peyton Place Miasha Miki
sayonara
Dian Fossey Peyton Place the winner is
Miyoshi Oh Mickey
[Applause]
[Music]
I really don't know what to say i I wish
somebody would help me right now cuz I
didn't expect so I had nothing in my
mind but right now I thank you for
everyone who helped me and you and you
and all American people
[Applause]
[Music]